Jeff we've gotten to the tail end of our
work with the story engine cards and the
story that you've developed how can we
take it to the Finish Line I know we
weren't exactly sure certain details but
we fleshed out a lot of interesting
options here right to to follow this
um
this trajectory which is basically
we're working with several of the seven
tools that I teach
including the 36 dramatic situations and
the Enneagram but the main one we're
focusing on here is dilemma
which consists of dilemma crisis
decision in action and resolution
so we've really solidified a dilemma to
the degree that we can
we have some good strong
possibilities for Enneagram types which
will inform the story more as it the
story progresses the thing that I would
do now is
focus on crisis
which is the Dilemma come to a head come
to a make or break point decision and
action in the face of Crisis and then
the resolution of the Dilemma
and once we have that then we've
completed
one pass through
one aspect of creating this story by
focusing mostly on dilemma which is the
way I start any story I kind of
grab the story and look at it through
the lens of dilemma because the
protagonist caught in a good strong
dilemma amplifies the dramatic power of
the story it really
helps imbue the story with dramatic
intensity
right from the beginning of creating it
so that you're building drama into the
story
from the beginning of the process rather
than inventing a story and then trying
to retrofit dramatic tension into it
so it sort of died in the wool
[Music]
so
The Next Step would be to
focus on the way in which this dilemma
comes to a critical juncture around the
end of act two
and because we've only got a tentative
but pretty solid statement of dilemma
we've got a sense of personality types
the thing to do would be to
focus on dilemma and we don't have to
like we're not going to solve it
comprehensively because the Dilemma is
still tentative and fluid
uh
but
we want to bring crisis up to the level
that we have the Dilemma at this point
so
in this type of story
what we're saying is that
so if I'm this robot which is one of the
ways I deal with dilemma as I put myself
in the position of the protagonist
and
like it's unacceptable to
do these morally reprehensible things
that the sun is
pushing me to participate in it's it's
kind of like the sun needs me
to actuate it otherwise he'd just go do
it himself why would I be in the middle
of the mix probably because I'm wired
into the whole Factory and that kind of
thing so he
he needs me to execute or to help
execute probably because I can do so
many functions at once he could do five
of them I could do 40 billion in a
second
it might take him all day to do five of
them so I'm required
so it's unacceptable to
participate in this morally
reprehensible
thing that my ethics programming kind of
forbids me from doing
and yet
and yet as a loyalist as a type six
potentially
a loyalist isn't all about giving
loyalty to someone else they're also
looking for loyalty
but the type six is
one of the most basic things about a
type six is that they're contradictory
they can be both selfless and selfish
they can be you know generous and stingy
they can be active and passive there's
all these different opposites that they
can embody
in one person
so
if
I'm this
like sentient robot of some kind not
necessarily sentient but a high-level AI
I can't
participate in these morally
reprehensible things and yet
um
I can't let go of
what the sun is offering me which is a
chance to be human
and I also have a need to like
be loyal
type sixes can be like blindly loyal
they're always questioning but once they
get beyond their questioning and they
really become loyal to something they're
also the type that can go down with the
ship they have trouble even if they see
they're wrong they're like I'm I'm all
in anyway
so
I can't
contribute to the morally reprehensible
stuff but I can't let go of this
opportunity to become human and I'm like
sort of naturally wired to
defend
the organization that I'm part of
and I'm starving to be human
so and there's this thing being put in
motion where
this company not just a company this
massive
Corporation that's probably similar to
the Tyrell Corporation potentially in
certain ways
[Music]
somewhere around the end of act two
it's about to be launched
and
the this robot has to
well the robot is still wrestling with
the Dilemma
really enjoying the perks of kind of
giddy humanness
going to the beach like doing stuff he
never did before and that presumes
there's
like a humanoid type body but that it
could still be a robot but could go
surfing girls are interested can eat a
hot dog can get sunburned
but it's still a robot but it's more
it's like Spock on catnip or whatever
um
and if the operating system is being
corrupted
then at the point of crisis
the inner facilities of this
automaton
are compromised to a dangerous level so
that right when this automaton needs
his faculties the most and it could
totally be a she
all of the any of these
it could all be women it could all be
anything
all of the the faculties that are needed
most are the ones that are most missing
at this crucial juncture
and
see one of the things about a crisis is
that it's often the worst possible
things happening at the worst possible
moment
and
one of
the aspects of the worst possible things
happening at the worst possible moment
can be that you're right on the very
precipice of total success
like why is everything falling apart
right I'm an inch away from undoing it
is working I'm pulling it off and it's
all going to hell right on the edge of
success that can be a crisis
so
the emerging humanoid aspects in the
personality of this
automaton
it can be like
it just got a girlfriend like it's like
it's like and it's going on a certain
you know it's like
like why now like
I'm they really think I'm human and I
feel like I'm human and it's working and
she likes me and I'm a good Surfer and I
you know it's like
it's way
worse to give that up now than it was
20 minutes earlier in the plot because
I'm like I'm addicted to being a person
and it's working or it's right on the
edge of working
um
you know it might be that the sun has to
I got to adjust you a little bit more
and then you won't even remember you
were used to be a robot you'll really
think you're this person and all that
type of stuff and he's like yes yes I
gotta have that and right at that point
is when
things
come to a head okay we're launching
tonight something happened we're moving
the launch date up so right now
and
we were also talking about how if the
automaton in seeking guidance because
the giddiness of Being Human
is really intoxicating and like
addicting
but
the kind of smoke alarm that's going off
in the brain of this automaton like
you're going to kill a billion people
like wake up what is going on like this
is wrong
like that's screaming in there too
and
and that's like the Dilemma that this
character has been wrestling with
throughout act two and as part of that
if he's reanimated the father
who created this whole company and the
father is like able to give him words of
wisdom and encouragement
then that can be helping him and
um
it's possible that at the point of
crisis
I first thought that the sun could kind
of pull the plug on this reanimation
even if it's just an AI that he's
brought to a level of fruition that he
can
um communicate with it
um
so have an intelligence so like he's
upgraded the AI aspects of the deceased
father so that it emulates his
personality enough that he can have like
a real conversation with who that person
really was for him
and like you can really you you can make
a decision and you're not weak and
you're a good person you know it's
saying all these things at first I
thought the sun might come along and
kill the father again if he's the one
that killed the father earlier on
but it could even be worse than that
like what if
the sun hears him getting words of
wisdom from the father and the son
starts laughing and like
you fell for all that crap and he like
hits a button so that like the real
father comes out and the real father
could be a treacherous malignant monster
just like the sun and that's like who he
really is
and just the disguise has come off
so that for this poor robot who's
desperately struggling to navigate the
demands of his ethics his moral compass
and his
incredible hunger to be human and to be
loyal
and at that point he finds out that the
founding father really was a like
sadistically vicious horrible creature
and that's why the sun turned out that
way even though he's great at hey he's
like everybody's best friend but he's
like this treacherous monster for that
to hit
this automaton right at the worst
possible moment
then you not only have
the kind of mental breakdown going on
inside the robot as the faculties that
he needs the most at this moment are
being corroded by the Sun as the
operating system is
corrupted more and more
but that the one person who is a Shining
Light and a source of belief and faith
in everything
is revealed to be by far
the worst monster in this entire
universe
it's such a crushing shock it's like a
back-breaking
taking away the one hope he had at the
worst possible moment and taking it away
in the worst possible way
like you know the father ends up
laughing at him like you fell for all
this you're such a loser you don't
know anything you know and we made you
like that you're a manipulable little
tin robot that does what we tell you and
is very happy about it loves everybody
you know it's like
you know and like you're trash you're
you served your function thank you like
get out
which is
um the Kinsmen slain unrecognized
and discovery of the dishonor of a loved
one and disaster and Madness all of
those things are constituting those are
some of the situations that are very
active at the point of crisis
and so it's like
you know the rug isn't just jerked out
from under this robot at this key point
but there's not even a floor anymore
he's like in free fall
but he's got to
make a decision about this world crisis
that's in the throes of it's happening
now
and
maybe part of him is actuating it now
like performing the computations like
he's been ordered because he is just a
robot or a puppet
and yet part of him is like screaming to
try and stop it
and so the decision in action is going
to be something like
this robot
makes a key decision that he's gonna try
to stop this
and takes an action a just a decision is
nothing that's just like okay I'll do
that but you could still be laying in
bed saying that it's getting up and
taking action so it's decision and
action in the face of crisis
and the decision in action are two sides
of the same coin it's one thing like you
see your kid about to get hit by a truck
you're not going hmm I better it's like
you're already through the window before
you even have a chance to think about it
you know like you're throwing the frying
pan and the stool right through the
window and you're getting cut to
and flying out there to rescue your kid
it's a decision and action in the face
of crisis
so for this
robot to take some kind of stand to try
to stop this thing which is already in
progress and looks like it's going to
win
and the robot may not be able to stop
its own processes but it's
gonna try to throw a monkey wrench in
there in fact the action would be to
throw a monkey wrench in there which may
or may not
win
but is no longer paralyzed like what am
I going to do when when I have to make a
choice now I've made a choice and I'm
going to war and it's the opening Salvo
in the fight to the Finish
and it's an attempt generally the
beginning of the fight to the Finish is
an honest attempt at a killing blow
like it's not only going to punch you
and then we're going to punch a whole
bunch more like I'm going to hit you so
hard that you die on impact that's the
intent of the beginning of the fight to
the Finish By the protagonist of a very
strong action that could win but you
have a very powerful antagonist so
you're evenly matched so from there on
out it's really a fight to the Finish
between the Sun
and possibly the AI of the father and
this robot over the fate of the world
and
if the robot
conclusively resolves his dilemma which
is the resolution in the end
and
is kind of a
desperate
attempt at
sabotage
to try to stop them
then the robot probably has to grow a
lot
to be able to conclusively resolve that
dilemma this is like a desperate
action and an emergency and this is more
like a comprehensive
massive victory that isn't going to
backslide if he beats them they're done
they're gone
they might be both dead or they might be
killed by the virus that they were gonna
but whatever it is he's really one and
he might still be a surfer on the beach
at the end
you never know
but um
so there's gonna have to be
you know it's the character it's the
completion of the character Arc
um and a real fight to the Finish and
because the antagonist is extremely
powerful then it's not a walk in the
park at all
to get from the point of decision and
action to the point of resolution this
is a declaration of war
and
it could easily be a catastrophic loss
for the automaton
but the automaton is growing changing
and maybe even still feeding on the
original words of the founding father
when the AI said you can do it you're
you're a good creature you're stronger
than you know
have trust in yourself
those might still be guiding words that
help
the robot
grow enough to defeat their treachery
and their power because even if the
robot has a great Victory five minutes
after the decision and action in the
face of crisis
the Sun and possibly the AI or the
father May
you know outweigh that with a really
treacherous powerful Act
and like now our automaton is seriously
getting his butt kicked
and like it's you know it's the back and
forth as the
automaton grows in capability confidence
and even sense of humanity
like a real conscience a real ability to
see
that that's wrong and I don't need my
computer to be going this is 72 percent
this way this is 19. it's like no that's
wrong and there's no like it's
just clear
so that
the resolution
if the
automaton wins in the end
the this automaton is using
some of the strengths of the villain and
of the corporation and
probably
humans that work in there
that he has turned into allies like you
know like you and whose Army it needs to
be like wickedly smart incredibly
forceful
no half measures
and you know
crushing truly treacherous lunatics who
will stop at nothing and who are
immensely powerful
so
this
the weak little automaton
that was like disabled by the Sun and
wondering about things when it never
used to
is now going to be by the end
a massively powerful Warrior whose
self-confident can make decisions
has a good strong sense of Ethics but
will also burn this whole Factory down
and if a couple hundred workers die in
that it's going to save billions and
prevent this great evil from coming out
so capable of making hard choices great
strength of character
Insight learned deviousness
learns how to fight dirty all of that
whatever it takes to conclusively
resolve the Dilemma that was paralyzing
him earlier on so he's a completely
different character at the end than he
was
you know for a big chunk of his dilemma
then you have
a powerful Dynamic ending you know and
it's possible he even converts the virus
that was going to kill a billion people
into
I don't know a vaccine that you know
ends
you know something on the Earth
so that because it was already too late
to stop the
distribution of it
but he can affect the chemistry of it as
it's being distributed so that it's
actually Ultra healthy for the people
that take it rather than they're going
to die in 19 hours or something like
that
um or it could you know it could be a
permanent cure for smallpox or you know
some of those things were already cured
but it could be something like that
um
and you know maybe the assistant of the
sun maybe when the sun said look when I
do this last step to you you really will
be a human
maybe the assistant of the sun is able
to do that step to him
so that we we see him on the beach and
he he'd still be this person of great
power I don't think you want to lose
that
but you know it would be like you know
seeing some really smart
powerful person on the beach just
hanging out having fun
um
so that you could see how that could be
one powerful resolution to this story
in a conclusive defeat of the sun and
the father's AI
and a prevention of this great
catastrophe and the destruction of this
power grab
and
once you can
isolate and articulate the resolution
which we've only partially articulated
at this point it's pretty tentative and
flexible and fluid but
um we can see it and you can see what it
is so that enables you to see the theme
of the story
and
the um
the best way to isolate and articulate
theme is to look at the resolution
and to look at the way in which the
protagonist resolves the Dilemma so it's
not what happens but the way in which
the protagonist does it because there
you have the completion of the
transformation of this character
and so this person who used to not trust
their own decision-making process and
need guidance from others and be unsure
and
suspicious
is now like I know what to do and I'm
you know unilaterally making all these
decisions
and I'm using my power and it's just
like he might even be hearing the
father's voice you know the the untrue
voice of the father but it's still true
for him you are a good creature use your
power don't let anybody tell you what to
do you don't need me to tell you what to
do so that he's like you know he's like
coming into power
and if you look at the way in which he
resolves The Dilemma you see that
tremendous growth of power and
confidence and capability and that's
what the story is about thematically
you can you can look right there there's
the theme
and
the thing about working with theme in
this way is that
you will have like a heart or gut level
understanding of it like you get it even
if you can't articulate it right away
um
and that's
that's a really
great place to be because you really
comprehend the theme
and the words you don't necessarily have
the words to be able to articulate it
clearly yet but that's okay because look
at what the audience when the audience
sees that movie and they walk out of the
theater and they feel that greatness of
heart that this character imbued in them
that they're taking the theme home with
them they've got it they feel that
greatness of heart and that's what the
the writer created that crafted that the
final effect is the principle effect the
ending is where the power of the whole
film comes together
um it's like cracking a whip the tail
end of it breaks the speed of sound and
that's what the sound is
and it's like being on a you know a a
chain one with skaters and everybody's
holding hands and the last person gets
whipped way out ahead
the the power of the whole story is
wrapped up and delivered through the
ending
so you're sculpting the mood that the
audience goes home in
and they take the theme home with them
and if you do it powerfully enough
you change their lives they never look
at the world the same after that that
greatness of heart
that they got from this story they they
can always go back to that
and it's very powerful
and like I remember when I
saw a Braveheart and I felt like that at
the end even though it was a weird sad
ending I felt that greatness of Heart of
Wallace and I'm actually reading Andrew
Carnegie's
autobiography now and he's Scottish and
grew up in Scotland and he said they
grew up on Wallace Wallace Robert the
Bruce who became king later and one
other guy and they said for a Scottish
kid he was our hero and we were like
Wallace wouldn't have stood down now
like we like they become indomitable and
it like impacted their life for for the
rest of his life he was always like
Wallace Bruce and whoever the other guy
was I can't remember but like you you
can really like shape somebody's
approach to life
like I still remember when I saw the end
of Blade Runner
it impacted me and it still does and
great movies with great endings
can really like permanently change how
an audience thinks and that's and they
do that to varying degrees all the way
from zero to a hundred percent like a
hundred percent is like you never look
at the world in the way you used to
again
and and then of course you know a lot of
it is just like you feel amazing for a
couple days or you feel beat up because
it was a rough ending but you learned
something from it
but it's it's you know the ambition of a
writer is to permanently change how
people think and you just look at the
resolution and look at the way in which
the protagonist resolves the Dilemma
that's the theme look at training day
the way in which Jake resolves his
dilemma is to absolutely stand for his
principles
Antoine Fuqua the director and David
Ayers the writer both said
training day is about what if one man
says no
and it's Jake's absolute ferocity I will
not stop I will not go away you're not
getting away with this no matter what
that's what that movie's about
thematically you can feel that coming
out of the theater that's in you
mm-hmm
so that's
that's like a quick run through
really dilemma crisis decision and
action resolution but because different
Enneagram types will react to a dilemma
in different ways that helps a lot and
you can see how the 36 dramatic
situations just who's like throwing
gasoline on a fire like I could see some
elements and you throw ambition and
Madness and conflict of the god and
rivalry of Superior and inferior and the
necessity of sacrificing loved ones
and you know all those types of things
gave us
ideas to create the story it's just a
set of it's a brainstorming tool it's a
suggestive possibilities it triggers
possibilities
um and there's obviously a whole bunch
more tools I have seven tools all
together but this is a good
look at
the main thing I'm doing here is as I
start
with a raw idea I go right to dilemma
and it's almost like
it's almost like the image of like
you might see like somebody in Africa
carving a drum and they're like working
on the drum but they're with their feet
they're holding the bottom of this thing
that's going to become a drum and they
clamp it in
and like I'm clamping on to dilemma as I
wrestle with the story so it's all about
the protagonist's Dilemma as I invent
the story I'm focused on dilemma as I
build the story
and that's a really fundamental skill in
using this tool and that dilemma is too
equally unacceptable Alternatives two
equally painful choices and it really
does that Robbie the robot like the
person is paralyzed between these two
equally unacceptable alternatives for
the whole second act the paralysis is
broken at the point of Crisis but it's
not until another 10 or 15 minutes of
movie at the resolution of the Dilemma
that the Dilemma exclusively
conclusively resolved and so it
constitutes
three quarters or more of the story and
occupies the full proportion of the
story it's not a little thing it's not a
a minor problem that crops up
so yeah it's it's a
it's a real
process that is extremely helpful in
essentially turning story into drama
because if it's just story then it's
mere information and it's not always as
gripping as it could be
and a good strong dilemma can turn a
good story
into a great drama
in any genre like you look at like Liar
Liar with uh Jim Carrey it's a fun
whacked out comedy but it has a dilemma
of magnitude there's substance to it
Tutsi is a fun comedy but there's a lot
of substance and depth and a good strong
dilemma
so it
it can work in any genre and obviously
if it's a completely whacked out comedy
then there'll be less magnitude and more
fun so it's obviously
you have a sense of how much of it you
need for a particular type of story
um
but you know the more familiar with it
the more and the more you understand the
underlying principles behind what makes
the tool work then you can adjust the
tool as needed for each specific type of
script that has different demands and
different tone and different intensity
and different impact on the audience
Jeff you've provided such valuable
information today and I love the way you
you question different story points if
someone wants to work with you what's
the best way they can find your
teachings uh you know become a student
of yours
well um
I have a couple different things I have
a book writing a great movie which will
walk you through all this and I build a
real script in the second half
I have a three-month pre-recorded
training program where we build a real
script in three months and it's you work
along with me
helping build the script and solving the
different puzzles involved as we build
it that's 65 hours of pre-recorded video
and then I have a two-year live training
program where we work five days a week
about two and a half hours a day and
that three months is the first part of
that so you can get live intensive
training for two years
and then uh we have a subscription
service where you can sign up and pay a
certain amount each month and have
ongoing access to live classes every
week pre-recorded trainings uh
writings and so on that kind of thing we
can have a link below as well for
viewers to click on so if I want to take
a class can I just choose which one or
do I is there a prerequisite before
taking some you can choose which one but
for the two-year the first part of that
is the three-month pre-recorded that's
called course one
because course two is continuously
ongoing
so like there's someone who just
finished course one yesterday who will
be joining course two and we're halfway
through writing a romantic comedy so he
and because he's built a whole Thriller
with me in course one he's conversing
with the tools
wrote the script based on the outline
that we created together so he can jump
right in and he has to learn about this
particular story but he's fluent enough
with the tools that he can just jump
right in and not be going wait what are
you guys talking about he's like yeah I
know how to I know my way around
and so it's it's um
it's designed so that
course one sets you up to jump right
into course two at any time
and then I do private Consulting as well
which anybody can get hold of me at
script.kitchen just Jeff at
script.kitchen there's no.com it's dot
kitchen
script.kitchen are most of your students
working adults taking this in addition
to their foreign
they have more time
um
but it's it's it's all across the board
and one of them is 15 living in Romania
they're like all over the world and all
different stages
you know it's it's a commitment of time
and
I'm not working
with any of my individual students own
screenplays because that's too
complicated but we're all working
together to build a script and they're
getting extensive hands-on experience
using all the tools in a collaborative
way
and then once they're once they've been
in course two
for long enough to feel like they really
have a handle on the tools then they
build their own script
in front of the group
to make sure that they can really do
this stuff themselves and we come by
every few days to check in on how
they're doing and they might want us to
brainstorm with them or you know they
might want to do it themselves I'd be
like looking at what they're doing what
did you just solve having them
articulate their thought process
um correcting them if they're doing
something technically slightly wrong
um
just to make sure that they really can
do this on their own
and that then you know they'll be
extremely skilled seasoned and versatile
as dramatists and you could throw them a
comedy a Horror Story a sports drama
anything and they're like they know how
to Grapple with it make it work
dramatically
think through the Deep aspects of the
story dimensionalize it build the
characters make it
fresh and different and not predictable
and cliche
you know I'm teaching some very powerful
tools and rigorous technique
but I'm always emphasizing
you gotta have a real sense of adventure
you know it's storytelling
and the more craft you have the less you
have to make safe choices people make
safe choices as writers because they
don't have the technique to make a
complex choice and make that work so
they make a safe choice because they
know they can make that work
but I really teach
Reckless abandon like explosive
creativity and like
drive off the get yourself in trouble if
you're not in over your head you're not
doing your job right
people don't want to see the same
lukewarm story Trot it out again
they want to see something where they're
going
what was that and like what just
happened and where is it going now you
know it's
that's the fun of being a writer and
you know so
and the other thing is that there's
these seven tools but fully half of what
I'm teaching is just pure seed of the
pants storytelling you're just making
stuff up and that's huge the tools are
just a part of that and they can shape
some of your processes and make the
things you choose work better and more
dramatic and more compelling and good
tight cause and effect so it moves well
without being bogged down by unnecessary
stuff
but
if your story is Bland and predictable
then you could just end up with
well-structured crap
so Mirror Technique is not enough you
really need explosive creativity and
Reckless abandon and
just a refusal to make safe choices and
the refusal to knuckle under the cliche
and all that type of stuff
so it's part wild animal and it's part
like domesticated animal where you
really can make concise rigorous choices
and technique but the thing that you're
applying that to
is you know like
a 30-foot gorilla that'll rip your arms
off in a second you're working hard to
make the tools go to that
the story is the master you're just the
person who's trying to make it work
dramatically
so it can be stage Worthy on TV on film
and theater